this morning we continue to follow the
lives of our nation's brightest bravest
rather as they return from war it's so
pronounced bravest we were there earlier
this year when a group of Marines came
home to North Carolina from
Afghanistan's Helmand province it has
been six months since that very
emotional reunion and now as part of our
come out series it's called coming home
we focus on the families of two Marines
Maj Ethan Crum now and Maj Paul Rivera
Jan Crawford is here with the strength
and sacrifice they've shown at home Jan
good morning well good morning and you
know I mean we hear this raise all the
time when we're honoring our nation's
heroes the families serve - that's right
you know what does that really mean for
a family to serve and how do they cope
when this huge hole opens up in their
home and then when a loved one comes
home and so much has changed and
especially for those with young children
when majors Ethan Crum now and Paul
Rivera first saw their families you
could feel the relief ready to go
[Applause]
[Music]
but after nine long months in
Afghanistan Krum now and his wife
Christina faced some surprises you had
this idea in your mind that like you'll
come home and they're like oh great
let's go play soccer and let's do this
and then you come home and they're more
into a TV show we're drawing in a book
on the other hand everyone wants to hold
dad's hand they want to sit by me at the
restaurant they want to do everything
with me they're not doing it on purpose
but then mom kind of becomes like yeah
mom we know you like you've been here
let's go back like this I'm the problem
solver but he's the fun guy Paul Rivera
also saw how things had changed it was
difficult because it was trying to find
some commonalities with him I know they
like Star Wars and so the thing was that
they had already been watching Star Wars
and they were like okay dad this is what
we've been watching we're almost done
while he was gone his wife Lily moved
some furniture to twin beds to the
master bedroom it was one of those
things where I guess a comfort for me
where I have all my babies in one spot I
guess that's what helped me sleep to it
right now for both families the children
are the focus was there a moment that
was especially hard it's the girls
saying for the Christmas concert and
they were crying but he wasn't there and
you can't console' them it's just not
gonna get any better
did you cry you know how did you do that
actually no I I did cry I try not to cry
for them just because I am a very
emotional person
and so I I do want them to know it hurts
it does it stinks but I have to console
them it's okay we've got this we can do
this mommy's still here daddy wasn't
there he was still at the gana stand for
kids the deployments can be hard to
process what was the day like when he
left every day I was in the car and we
were crying a long time what were you
thinking then she he make dice and she
was working so hard he might die were
you afraid mm-hmm
the crumb nails have seen the
separations take a toll on their son
family functions is stuff like that
Franklin would like pair up with some
other dad or some you know somebody no
sorry
that was was familiar but to me that
like confirmed that he really was
missing
the Rivera house it's much the same I
was like no please don't make him go
please please like no I want him to go
the kids find their own ways to cope I
basically just saw he's coming the next
day he's coming next day he's coming the
next day pretty much shot me through the
whole thing when the Rivera's are
separated with Paul serving in dangerous
combat zones they rely on their faith
I'd wake up and and just go in my closet
and pray for 15 minutes and that was the
one thing I did every day I just felt
like I needed a pickup because they you
didn't know what the day ahead was going
to be yes and just emotionally I mean
I'm by myself here through multiple
deployments Rivera has learned to be
there when he can even surprising her on
special holidays it was a little
scavenger hunt so I pre-staged things
throughout the house to surprise her do
me a favor and I need you to go to this
room and I need you to move these books
out of the way and happy anniversary I
moved it out of the way and it was a
little famous blue box sorry a while
with dad now home the crumb nails hold
barbecues for family and friends to
celebrate the times they do have
together it's really fun with them too
he could see a fun guy
yeah he's silly he is yes what does he
like to do drink beer in some sense it
brings us closer together
now that we were gone for a while it
kind of makes it more meaningful both
wives recognized the true meaning of
sacrifice their needs come second
he doesn't particularly belong to me he
belongs to the government so he goes and
does things that you know his
responsibilities and I'm looking and
that has to come first it does that's
the sacrifice for those back home who
served by staying strong is he gonna
stay here for a while do you think I
hope so I hope so much I think he has to
have another deployment yeah and how
will you guys get through that
by acting good oh and you can see I mean
even from those little kids the mix of
resolve and hope that all these families
have I mean they're ready just for the
next challenge and that that bravery I
mean we talked about the bravery of our
our servicemen and women but the bravery
of those families oh the kids were so so
so poignant
yeah in how they talked about their
parents and I love the one little person
that said what does your dad like to do
drink beer but it but it's such a good
reminder though behind all of the
soldiers who were serving there are
people that loved them dearly that
deeply care about them in addition to
the country's admiration you've got
families that really exactly care about
them yeah it's beautifully done Jen yeah
that's great thank you - thank you it's
nice to be there until Astoria Thank You
Jan